okay our back we're just doing the next
mission I took like two steps so here we
go the [ __ ] is this the [ __ ] is that
okay
you
I'll a [ __ ]
[ __ ] that is a big bomb
you
that [ __ ] is where did
okay let's do this
can I go to water and they got tickets
down here what is that that is that ah
girls and spatula and I thought I
wouldn't say that
oh yeah shut your mouth you [ __ ] yes
happy to zania that's your best defense
ah
oh ow ow ow ow
where is it
oh [ __ ]
you
you
you
what's up [ __ ]
okay I'm gone down I'm saying it's a
bouquet here we go
sure I'm running low on ammo okay so I
can save my for sure hey [ __ ] saving
[ __ ] [ __ ] shed out
I
now I wish my thing was [ __ ] stronger
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh it's gone now
that's it this thing cuz its wings are
like higher in here exchange how to just
just uh paired up soil the [ __ ]
actors do
if I open that - over there and I'm here
I'm at abandoned dress what Mario on
[ __ ] shut
that's shat
what's going on with that thing why did
I die
oh they shed a lot of [ __ ] Nazis okay
why does that guy choose to show up yeah
like no backup
okay I get it straight through it now
out you [ __ ]
ah
dear cat surprise might have okay okay
okay okay that says I should go this way
I think right now that's why all right
that complements why
oh yeah I can't feel this way so let me
go up then I guess or should I get I
can't I guess I'll go up I'll get
posters yes okay to them yeah just just
general like just confuse once again we
have to hug that there we go
I got no ammo instead of helping it's
not bad
the [ __ ] is that spines central nervous
system
okay well I guess I got a lay back oh so
that [ __ ] is that
holy [ __ ] it's that gay guy well he just
look at the face of climax look at the
face that's frost
a boyfriend if it always like Bob is
like yeah you know what I'm saying
very awkward
she loves cows you know girl girls are
girls I love gifts
Wow [ __ ] act manic episodes they had
like webcams oh hey I need that yeah can
you shave her lipids oh yeah
oh good hey babbit Oh does she climax
was a noise so much the climax hello
Lala okay well you know tonight automata
I may have like two people just just now
Wow
dope I feel pretty sick like a lot come
on
holy [ __ ] how the [ __ ] is this guy still
love it that he died idly John delay
let's look at Anya Oh [ __ ] Frau you
got it baby
what's the name Tom bata or something
basta the blotter that's why we to go
with [ __ ] on hand the other person
watching we [ __ ] left behind
yeah of course
and arnica
this guy is like [ __ ] fearless
ah very - I like this guy
so I will Tim there we go and when I got
better given a massage a little neck
massage later yeah thank you
so
you
you
ah okay
you
you
he's like it's so Chuck and shock the
davidic oh [ __ ] great this sucks I need
some [ __ ] out out out how you app I'm
not doing well
fucking-a what the [ __ ] am I supposed to
do
[Music]
now I honestly have no idea what I'm
supposed to do
hold on
whereas a
five
what is this
[ __ ] it does anyone know what the
[ __ ] do why is this a maxout Oh
like that best
[ __ ] I met
app app okay what the [ __ ] come on oh
[ __ ]
I got you [ __ ]
you
you
all right hat
you
you
you're mad bro
you
[ __ ] disgusting
all right
you
okay out that was a [ __ ] app okay set
out ow ow
what the [ __ ] is all this out chef I get
out of here [ __ ]
fast shut up
sigh sigh another one
okay how do I the [ __ ]
okay I can't go left can I go right is
there someone else out here now check
okay I think I gotta go to the other
side then but I'm going to shot up bad
here guys [ __ ] crow [ __ ] okay here we
go here we go [ __ ] an egg like ten miles
away
there we go here we go ah ah ah
now how [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] I have anymore the
[ __ ] going on here huh [ __ ] with that
where is he ready go yes step is that
okay with him okay I'm going to need
some help now
yes yeah bad [ __ ] okay let's take a
I'll take a little break and go and get
some help here where is it where is it
you can't [ __ ] see him I can't say
[ __ ] I can't see [ __ ]
Hut [ __ ] anymore out where the [ __ ] is a
help where are they
come on bet yes stupid [ __ ] at [ __ ]
where is it
you
shut [ __ ] dot can't [ __ ] see you
[ __ ] [ __ ] up isn't there [ __ ]
yes stupid [ __ ] you go [ __ ] yourself
you [ __ ] [ __ ] out get hurt I'm
getting a low heart come on come on come
on come on come on out okay I know this
[ __ ] is their [ __ ] health
character on you somewhere well what'd I
miss
where are they where are they
where are they there we go back time to
set my deck open their jaw unhinge your
jaw like a snake
you
ooh the [ __ ] is that check so I can
email back
there's no way how's this face not [ __ ]
you
you
sure
add as much s signing up captain black
wow that's a really good game
holy [ __ ] I really like that ending how
does that work those in the hammock
locking star the second one
nobody knows where they're super kinetic
ribs okay well I guess a little service
here if there's something at the app
[ __ ] Google it ok I'm not here to
entertain not again kind of I get really
sick okay well [ __ ] can't talk about it
so I guys are staying there get some
[ __ ] enchanting
I'm still here I just [ __ ] clear my
sinuses my client every table you have
to go eggplant over okay thank you
Valon boys I'm stuck at the coaster
casing and my balance of the ocean and
up to this okay 9s rightness shot I get
to work for dinner tonight
okay we're going to say something rather
like crawling out of rollers I think I'm
on at least six programmers if this
makes guys game if you gottem it even
though you know what they don't make
grade III put presentation that sockets
sucked
your outside let's make sign ah
because credits are way too long you
know and I'm just not against unskipable
trailers you know okay
sounds great so we'll just [ __ ]
probably see any sleep music door okay
and eyeliner that is somebody that is
like the cinnamon invite saying like why
do you follow me
Kenny message heavy message and I'm at
MSS I've never said it before delight
sorry Jeff Henry Ella in not coming
after me okay
they're not coming after me I need like
a [ __ ] salad
hi auntie in Lawndale acondo yet I get a
walking I'm sitting I'm way too [ __ ]
much
anyway that same I'm going to play is
called kingdom loathing it's like a
stick based RPG pretty excited about
German testers that's pretty ballsy to
get German people to play this holy [ __ ]
it's like hey can you like give me a
tennis game LZ is okay it's like [ __ ]
trash ism it's [ __ ] up
that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ] they got pay
its up okay we know we [ __ ] the struck a
thing as long how many [ __ ] AK so
here's all the Italian actors can't they
just like set like what's up with the
unskipable credits like come on like why
don't they just let you skip it and if
you missed the [ __ ] ending it was the
[ __ ] anything how they [ __ ] force
you to do this we have us calm there we
go
Spanish audio here so long Tyrell
alright yes may up tall Pradesh head on
so often that [ __ ] okay
I think it like that chicken nugget so
like cystic one not like to just a one
okay here we go let's say we're having a
blast events we all know you [ __ ] it's
arrived so sound like a special treat
that people that went to grad you can't
skip it okay yes I kinda helicopters
gone back
liberation now what the [ __ ] I guess
that is it okay well guys [ __ ] me about
huh okay why do I thank for watching
y'all sorry you had to be forced to that
credit tough [ __ ] oh yeah yes